[Music]
the new world order
the times that are coming will be
radically different from what we have
experienced so far in our
lifetime
but they will resemble many other stages
of history as I know because it
has always been that way
[Music
] throughout my  Approximately 50
years of global macroeconomic inversion
I have learned the hard way that the
most important events that surprised me
did so because they had never happened
to me before
these painful surprises led me to
study the last 500 years of
history of similar situations where
I saw that they had indeed  happened
before many times with the ups and downs of
the formerly
British
and American black empires
and each time they happened they were a sign of
a new world order
[Music]
studying this taught me valuable
lessons which I will pass on to you here in distilled form you will
find the full version
in my book  principles for dealing with
the new world order
let me begin  r with a story that
brought me to this point how i learned to
foresee the future by studying the past
[Music]
in 1971 when i was a young employee on
the floor of the new york stock exchange the
usa ran out of money and did
n't deliver  with its debts that's right the usa
ran out of money as well at that
time gold was the money used
in transactions between countries
paper money or bills like the dollar
was like checks in a check book in
the sense that it had no other value
Apart from the fact that it could be exchanged for gold,
which was real money
at that time, the United States spent much more
money than it earned and gave much more
of those paper money checks than the
gold it had in the bank to exchange
for them, as people had  these
guys to the bank to get
gold money the amount of gold in the us had
diminished it soon became clear that the
us could not keep its promises because of
all the existing paper money so
those who had dollars  s were
rushing to redeem the before
the gold ran out
acknowledging that the us would run out of
real money on sunday
night august 15 the president in sana'a
appeared on television to tell
the world that the us was breaking its promise to
allow  people to exchange their dollars
for gold
of course he did not say so he said it more
diplomatically without making it clear that
if the usa was breaching
the strength of a nation's currency it is
based on the strength of that
nation's
economy and the us economy is  by
far the strongest in the
world accordingly i have instructed the
secretary of the treasury to take
the necessary steps to defend the
dollar against speculators
i have instructed the secretary to
temporarily suspend the
convertibility of the dollar into gold or other
reserve assets  except in the amounts and
conditions that are determined in the interest
of monetary stability and in the
best interest of the united states,
looked with a
gloomy realizing money was running out
as we understood it
what a crisis i was
expecting the stock market to
crash the next day so i
got to the stock market floor early to get
ready when the opening bell rang
pandemonium broke out but not
as expected  market was
up
good up
and it goes on like that until it's up almost 25%
that surprised me because I've
never experienced a currency devaluation before
when I dug through history I found out
that the exact same thing happened in
1933 and it had the exact same
effect then as well  paper dollars
were pegged to gold that the
us was running out of because it was spending more
paper money checks than it
had gold to redeem them for and
president roosevelt announced on the
radio that he would break the country's promise
to trade dollars for gold
it was then that he issued the
proclamation establishing the
national bank holiday
and this was the first  r step in the government's
rebuilding of
our financial and
economic structure the second that happened last Thursday
was legislation
quickly and patriotically passed by congress
confirming my proclamation and expanding
my powers to make it possible
given the need for time to extend
the  holiday and lifting the limitation on
that holiday gradually over the next few
days this act also gave the
authority to develop a program
in both cases breaking the link to
gold allowed the us to continue spending
more than it earned by
simply printing more paper dollars as it
increased  the number of dollars without an
increase in the wealth of the country the value
of each dollar
fell as these new dollars
entered the market without a
corresponding increase in productivity they were
used to buy large amounts
of stocks gold and commodities
making their  prices
increased as I studied more history I saw
because the same thing had happened
many many times before
and that since the dawn of time
when governments spent much more
than they took in taxes and
conditions will get worse they ran out of
money and needed more so they
printed more much more
making their  value will fall and
the prices of almost everything will rise
including stocks gold and
commodities
that's when I first learned
this principle when central banks
print a lot of money to
alleviate a crisis you buy stocks gold and
commodities because their value will
rise and the  value of paper money
will fall this printing money happened
also in 2008 to alleviate
the mortgage driven debt crisis
and in 2020 to align the
economic crisis caused by the pandemic and it will
almost certainly happen in the future
so i suggest you keep in mind
account this principle
these experiences gave me another
principle to understand what you
see  And you must understand that it happened
before you are that principle led me to
study how the bubble of the
bustling 1920s
became the depression of the 1930s
which taught me to anticipate and take advantage
of the 2007 bubble that became
the crash of  2008
all these experiences led me to
develop an almost instinctive drive
to look for similar situations in the
past to learn how to handle
the future well
new orders
[Music]
in the last few years three big things
that had not happened in my life
led me to do this
study firstly some countries did not have
enough money to pay off their debts
even after lowering interest rates
to 0% so their
central banks started printing a lot of
money to do so secondly
major internal conflicts arose
due to widening gaps  of
wealth and values ​​this is manifested
in political populism and the
polarization between the left  da that
wants to redistribute wealth and the
right that wants to defend those who
own the wealth and thirdly the
growing external conflict between a
rising great power and the
leading great power as is currently happening
between china and the usa
so look back and  that all
this had happened many
times before and had almost always led to
changing national and world orders
the last time this sequence occurred
was from 1930 to 1945
you may be wondering what exactly
an order is a system of government
for people  treat each other there are
internal orders to govern within
the countries normally established in
the constitutions and there is a
world order that governs between countries
normally established in treaties
the internal orders change at
different times than the world orders and
both within the countries or between them
these orders usually change after
these more
civil wars within
g countries  international wars between countries
happen when new
revolutionary forces defeat
old and weak orders
for example the internal order of the usa
was established in the constitution in
1789 after the
american revolution and continues to function today
even after the secession war in
the united states  -russia got rid of
its old order and established a new one
with the russian revolution of 1917 which
ended in 1991 with a
relatively peaceful revolution china started its
current internal order in 1949 when the
chinese communist party won the
civil war you will have already understood the
world order  current commonly called
the us world order was formed
after the allied victory in
world war ii
from which the us emerged as the
dominant world power was established in
agreements and treaties on the
functioning of world governance
and monetary systems in 1944
the new world monetary system was created
by the agreement  of bretton woods that
established the dollar as the main
reserve currency in the world
a reserve currency is a currency that
is commonly accepted throughout the
world
owning it is a key factor for a
country to become the richest and most powerful empire
with a new power  dominant and a
new monetary system established
a new world order begins
these changes take place in a
timeless and universal cycle which he called the
great cycle i will
start with a brief
overview and then give you a fuller version
after that i will refer to my book if
you want to know more
by studying the ten most
powerful empires of the last 500 years
while last three reserve currencies
go through the rise and fall of the
empire of the netherlands and the florin
the british empire and the pound
sterling the rise and fall early
of the us empire and the dollar
and the decline and rise of the chinese empire
and its currencies
as well as the rise and fall of  the
empires of spain germany france and
india japan russia and the ottoman together with
their significant conflicts
as measured in this graph to
better understand the patterns of china
also study the rise and fall
of chinese dynasties and their currencies going
back to the year  62 since
looking at all these indices at once
can be confusing i will focus on
the four largest countries netherlands
uk usa and china
you will quickly see the pattern
now we simplify a bit as you will see they
occurred in overlapping cycles of
about
250 years with transition periods of
10 to 20 years between them
these transitions were usually
periods of great conflict because the
leading powers do not decline without a fight
so as I am measuring the power of
an empire
in this study I used eight metrics the
measure of the total power of each country is
obtained by averaging the 8
these are
inventive education and technological development
competitiveness in market  world countries
economic output
share of world trade
or military wine the power of its
financial center in the capital markets and
the strength of its currency as a reserve currency
because these forces are
measurable we can see how strong
each country is now and  in the past and whether it
is booming or busting
by looking at sequences from many
countries
we can see how a typical cycle goes
and how the ripples can
confuse us we can simplify a bit
to focus on the pattern
of cause and effect relationships that
drive the  rise and fall of a
typical empire
as you can see a better education
usually leads to more innovation and
technological development
and with some delay to the positioning
of the currency as a reserve currency
you will also see that these forces
then diminish in a similar order
reinforcing each other's strengths  cadences
let us now look at the typical sequence of
events within a country that produces
these rises  s and casualties
in a nutshell the grand cycle
normally begins after a
major conflict often a war
defines the new leading power and the
new world order as no one wants to
challenge this power
a period of peace and
prosperity generally follows as the  people get
used to this peace and prosperity
bet more and more that it will continue and
borrow money to do so
which eventually leads to a financial bubble
the empire's share of
trade grows and when
most transactions are done in its
currency this  it becomes a
reserve currency leading to even greater indebtedness
at the same time this increased prosperity
distributes wealth
unequally so that the wealth gap between
rich and poor
ultimately increases the weird financial bubble
leading to printing money
and rising  internal conflict between
rich and poor which in turn leads to
some form of revolution  ion to
redistribute wealth this can
happen peacefully or as a
civil war as the empire struggles with
this internal conflict its power
declines relative to
rival rising external powers
when a new rising power
becomes strong enough to
compete with the rising power  ruling class
suffering from internal crises
external conflicts occur usually wars out
of these internal and external wars
new winners and losers arise
then the winners come together
to create the new world order and the
cycle begins again
when I look back I saw that these
causal relationships  and effect they drove
the boom-and-bust cycles from the
Roman Empire to the present day I saw
how the stories of each of these
cycles merged with
earlier,
contemporary, and later ones just
as each individual story blended
with others to create the epic story
of  500 years that is our history
collective
and like the cycles of human life
no two are exactly alike but
most are similar they
are driven by logical relationships
of cause and effect that go through stages
from birth to potency and
maturity to weakness and
inevitable decline
however  that's like saying that
a person's life cycle lasts 80
years on average without recognizing that
many are much shorter and many are
longer although age can be a
good indicator of future longevity the
best way is to look at indicators of
health
one can also do that with
empires and their vitals i
found that by looking at the
power change indicators i could see what
stage a country was in which helped me
anticipate what was likely to come
next
now i'll take you through the grand cycle with
more detail give me 20 minutes and i'll give you
the last 500 years of history
and show you the similar patterns in
the empires dutch british
e  american and chinese
500 years of great cycles i
am going to describe the typical cycle by
dividing it into three phases
boom top and bust
the
car new emerging orders both
internal and external
are usually started by powerful
revolutionary leaders who do four
things first rise to power by
getting  more support than the
opposition secondly they consolidate power by
becoming militant or eliminating
the opposition so that it does not stand
in their way thirdly they establish
systems and institutions that make
the country work well and fourthly they
choose their successors well or  they create systems
that do because a great empire
requires many great leaders
over several generations
at this stage soon after winning the
fight there is usually a period of peace
and growing prosperity because the
leadership is clearly dominant and
has wide support so  nobody
wants to fight it during this phase the
leaders of the country of  they must design an
excellent system to increase the
wealth and power of the country in the first
place to be great they must have a
strong education that is not only teaching
knowledge and skills but
also strength of character civics and
work ethic
this is usually taught in high school
family schools and religious institutions
thus provide a
healthy respect for rules and laws
order within society
lowers corruption and enables them to
unite for a common purpose and
work well together as they
do increasingly change  from producing
basic products to
innovation and invention of new
technologies
for example the dutch went on
to defeat the
hapsburg empire and became
superbly educated became so
inventive that they developed a
quarter of all
the world's most important inventions the most
important in  They were the ships
capable of traveling all over the world.  he world to
collect great wealth and
capitalism as we know it
today to finance those trips
they like all leading empires
improved their thinking by opening up to the
best thinking in the world as a
result the people and the country become
more productive and more competitive  in
world markets
which is manifested in their
growing economic output and
increasing share of world trade
you can see this happening now as the
us and china are roughly
comparable in both their
economic output and their share
of world trade
as countries trade more
globally they are able to protect their
trade routes and
overseas interests against attack thereby
developing great military power
if executed correctly this
virtuous cycle leads to strong
revenue growth which can be used
to fund investment  in education
infrastructure and i  Research and
development must also develop
systems to incentivize and empower
those with the ability to create
or take wealth in all of these cases
the most successful empires used a
capitalist approach
to develop
productive entrepreneurs a Chinese led by the
Chinese Communist Party used a form  of
this capitalist approach
[Music]
den xiaoping when asked about
this he said it doesn't matter if it's a
white cat or a black cat as long as I caught
mice and it's also glorious to be rich
to do well they must develop their
capital markets most importantly
their markets  credit bonds and shares
this allows people to turn their
savings into investments
to finance invention and
development
and share in the successes of those who make
wonderful things happen
the dutch created the first
publicly traded company the
dutch east india company and the
first stock market in finan
ciar which were integral parts of the
system that produced enormous wealth and
power as a natural consequence the
largest empires develop the world's
major financial
centers to attract and distribute
world capital
amsterdam was the world financial center
when during the primacy of
the netherlands
london  when the british were
on top new york is now and china
is rapidly developing its
financial centers and most importantly
the capitalists the government and the
military must work together the
dutch not only worked well
together but were one and the same the
government gave a  trade monopoly
to the dutch east india company
which had its own
military force officially authorized to
go out into global markets to create
and take wealth
the british followed with
the british east india company
with a similar coordination
of their government operations
trade and military emnamentals the
US military industrial complex
followed suit as did the current Chinese system
as the country becomes the
largest international trading empire
its transactions can be paid for with
its currency
making it the
preferred global medium of exchange and as  its
currency is so widely accepted and
frequently used that people
all over the world want to save in it
making it the preferred store of value
and therefore the world's main
reserve currency
the guilder was the world's main
reserve currency when the
the dutch led in
world trade the pound was during the
british leadership and the dollar has been
since the us leadership began
naturally the chinese currency is being
used more and more as a
reserve
currency having a reserve currency allows the
empire to borrow  more than other
countries
that advantage is enormous
think about it the people  People from all over the world are
eager to save and therefore
lend their currency back to the
empire countries without a reserve currency don't
have that and when the empire runs out of
its own money remember the
us in 1971 can always print more
the exorbitant privilege granted by the
reserve currency of the empire leads to
increased indebtedness and the beginning of
a financial bubble
this series of cause and
effect relationships that lead
to mutually supporting political and military financial powers
reinforced by the power of indebtedness
of a reserve currency
come together since history is recorded
every empire that became the most
powerful in the world followed this path to
the top
[Music]
while in the upper phase
most of these powers are preserved
the fruits of their  success carry within them
the seeds of their decline
as a general rule as the
people of these rich and
powerful countries earn more.  more become more expensive
and less competitive compared to
those in other countries willing to
work for less
at the same time and people in other
countries naturally copy the methods and
technologies of the leading power
thus further reducing the competitiveness
of the leading power
by  example the British shipyards
had less expensive workers than the
Dutch
so they hired
Dutch designers to design better ships
built by
less expensive British workers making them more
competitive which led the British to rise
and the Dutch to decline as well
as people get richer tend  to
not work so hard
enjoy more free time seek the
better and less productive things in
life and become decadent when reaching the extreme
values ​​change from generation to
generation during the rise to the top
from those who had to struggle to
achieve wealth and  power to those
who inherit it  ron
are less battle hardened full
of luxury and accustomed to the easy life
which makes them more vulnerable to
challenges
the golden age of the Dutch empire
and the Victorian era of the British
[Music]
were periods of great prosperity like
this as  people get used
to doing well bet more and
more on the good times to continue and
take on debt to make that bet
which naturally creates financial bubbles
financial gains are made unevenly and
wealth gaps widen wealth
gaps  wealth are self-reinforcing
because the rich use their greater
resources to expand their powers,
for example, they grant greater privileges
to their children, such as access to
a better education, and influence the
political system to their advantage, this
generates gaps in values
policies and opportunities for
development between the rich
and the poor, those who do not have
the  less affluent feel that the
system is unfair so
resentment increases but while the standard of
living for most people continues to
rise these gaps and
resentments do not translate into
conflict having
the world's reserve currency inevitably
leads to excessive debt  and contributes
to the country accumulating large debts with
foreign lenders
although this increases
purchasing power in the short term in the long term it
weakens the financial health of the country and
the currency
in other words when
borrowing and spending are strong the
empire looks very strong
but in fact its finances are
weakening
the indebtedness sustains the power of the
country beyond its real base by
financing both the excessive internal consumption
and the international military conflicts
necessary to maintain
the empire
inevitably the costs of maintaining and
defending the empire exceed the income
that they contribute for which they have  r an empire
becomes unprofitable for example the
dutch empire
overextended itself around the world and waged
one after another increasingly expensive wars
against the british and other
european powers to protect its territory
and trade routes similarly to
the british empire  it became a
massive bureaucratic apparatus and lost its
competitive advantages as
rival powers in particular germany
took flight leading to an
increasingly expensive arms race
and a world war the
us has spent some $8
trillion on foreign wars and their
aftermath  since 9/11
and trillions more on other
military operations and maintaining military bases
in 70 countries
and still not spending enough to
maintain its military competition with
china in the area around it
in this cycle richer countries
eventually get more and more indebted  more
by borrowing from poorer countries
that save more one of the first  these are
signs of a transfer of wealth
and power this started in the us in the
1980s when it had a per
capita income 40 times that of
china and started borrowing from the
chinese who wanted to save in dollars
because the dollar was the currency  reserve
of the world
similarly the united kingdom- borrowed a lot of
money from their much
poorer colonies and the dutch did
the same at their top
if the empire starts to run
out of new lenders those who
have their currency start trying to
sell
and  go out instead of buy save
borrow and go in
[Music]
and the strength of the empire begins to
decline
the of flip
the decline comes from
internal economic weakness coupled with
internal infighting or costly external infighting or
both
usually the decline is gradual and
then abrupt
when the debts become very
large and there is an economic recession
and the empire can no longer borrow
the necessary money  to pay its
debts
the financial bubble bursts
this creates great internal difficulties
and forces the country to choose between
defaulting on its debts or printing a
lot of new money it always chooses to
print a lot of new money at
first gradually and
finally massively
that it does  losing value of the currency and
increasing inflation for the
Dutch this was the
financial crisis caused by the
financial excesses and the financing of the
fourth Anglo-Dutch War
similarly for the British it was to
pay for their financial excesses and for
their debts from the two world wars
and for the us there have been three cycles of
debt financed booms and busts
since the 1990s with the
central bank stepping in with
ever stronger measures
when the government has trouble
financing itself when
economic conditions and living standards are poor
of most people are
declining and there are large gaps  s of
wealth values ​​and policies
the internal conflicts between the rich
and the poor as well as the different
religious and racial ethnic groups
increase considerably
this leads to political extremism
manifesting as
left or right populism
those on the left seek to redistribute
wealth while  that the right-wingers
seek to keep wealth in the hands of
the rich
in those times it is common for
taxes on the rich to increase and when
the rich fear that
their wealth and well-being will be taken away from them, they move to
active places and currencies in which  they
feel safer these
outflows reduce
empire tax revenues leading to a
classic self-reinforcing hollowing out process
when wealth flight becomes
severe enough governments
prescribe it those seeking to leave
start to panic these
turbulent conditions undermine
global productivity reduce the economic
cake  economic and causes more conflict over
how to divide dwindling resources
populist leaders emerge from both
sides and vow to take
control and bring order that is when
democracy faces its greatest
challenge as it fails to control
anarchy and that is when  most likely the
move to a strong populist leader who
will bring order out of
chaos as the conflict within the
country escalates leading to some
form of revolution or civil war to
redistribute wealth and force the
big changes needed
this can be peaceful keeping  the
existing order
[Music]
but more often it is violent and
changing
for example the roosevelt revolution
to redistribute wealth was
relatively peaceful and maintained the
existing internal order
while the french
revolution the russian revolution and the chinese revolution
were much more violent and  led
to new internal orders
this internal conflict weakens the
empire and  makes it vulnerable to
rising external rivals who,
seeing this internal weakness, are more
inclined to pose a challenge
this increases the risk of a major
international conflict particularly if
the rival has built up a
comparable military force
defending itself and the
empire itself against  its rivals demand large
military spending
that has to occur while
domestic economic conditions are
deteriorating and the empire can least
afford it
given that there is no viable system
for peacefully settling
international disputes these
conflicts are normally resolved
through tests of
power as  bolder challenges are posed
the leading empire is faced with
the difficult choice of fighting or
retreating
fighting and losing is the worst outcome
but retreating is also bad as it
yields progress to the rival and signals to
those countries considering
which side to choose that  the empire is weak
the bad conditions  economic ions bring
more struggle for wealth and power
which inevitably leads to some
kind of war wars are
terribly costly
at the same time they produce the
tectonic shifts that realign
the new orders with the new
realities of wealth and power in
the world
when those who own the
reserve currency and bonds of the
declining empire lose faith and sell them
that marks the end of their great cycle
of the 750 or so currencies that have
existed since 1700
less than 20 percent now exist and all of them
have lost value  for the dutch
this happened after their defeat in the
fourth anglo dutch war when
they were unable to pay off the massive debts they
had accumulated during it
this led to many running to the bank
of amsterdam
and a desperate sale forcing
massive money printing
which devalued  currency
and empire to irrelevance
in the case of the British this is
It happened after the second
world war because despite their victory they
were unable to pay off the huge debts they
had incurred to finance their
war effort this led to a series
of money printing devaluations and
sales of the pound sterling
as the us and the dollar emerged
dominant  and they were creating a new
world order at the time of this recording the
usa has not yet reached this point
although it has massive debt it spends more
than it earns and finances this deficit
with more loans and by printing huge
amounts of new money the big
dollar sale  and debt in dollars has not
yet started and although there are great
internal and external conflicts that
occur for all the classic reasons
they have not yet crossed the line to
become wars eventually
these conflicts are violent or
new winners come together and
restructure  the debts and political systems
of the losers and establish
the new world order
then the old cycle and the empire
ends and the new one begins and they do it
all over again there are many details
that I have just given to paint a picture
of how the typical great cycle
goes of course they don't all go
exactly like that but most do
until  to the point that it seems like the
stories of rise and fall
remain essentially the same and the
only thing that changes is the clothes
the characters wear and the technologies they
use
so where are we headed
[Music]
the
future most empires have  their
time in the sun and they inevitably
go into decline
reversing a decline is difficult because it
requires undoing a lot of what
has already been done but it is possible by
looking at these indicators it is quite
easy to see what phase of the great cycle
an empire is going
through what state it is in and  whether your
condition is getting better or
worse which can help you estimate how many
years you have left
even though these estimates are not  n
accurate and the cycle can be prolonged if
those in charge pay attention to their
vital signs and improve them for example
knowing that a person is 60 years old
his physical condition if he smokes or not and some
other basic vital signs
his longevity can be estimated
one can also do  that with the
empires and their vital signs
will not be precise
but it will be broadly indicative and will give
a clear orientation on the steps
that must be taken to increase
longevity
in most cases the greatest
war of a nation is with itself
on whether or not it can  making the
tough decisions necessary to stay
successful
in terms of what we have to do comes
down to two things
earning more than we spend and
treating each other right all the
other things I've mentioned
strong education inventiveness competitiveness and
all that  others are just ways to achieve
these two things it
is easy to measure if we are doing them
so like the people
who want  eren get in shape let's get in
the program and improve our
vital signs let's do it
individually and collectively
my goal in sharing this image of
how the world works and some
principles to face it well is to
help you recognize where we are and the
challenges that we face  face and
make the wise decisions necessary
to navigate well in these times
[Music]
as there is much more to discuss and we are out of
time you can learn more
in my book Principles for Confronting
the New World Order and I look forward to
continuing this conversation on economic
principals  period or heretic and on
social networks
thank you very much and may the force of
evolution be with you
the new world order
[Music]
a
i
y
[Music]